what does this community like 70% are
let's you know an african-american it's
a working-class community how hard is it
to get people in a town like this
motivated to take on something this big
there are amazing people that I have met
here that maybe have not ever been a
part of a campaign in their lives have
never spoken publicly have never knocked
on doors and they're doing it it's
almost like everyday people have to
learn how to be activists absolutely
Christine says that while a big part of
the beyond call strategy is to encourage
locals to lead the charge talking only
about climate change isn't enough in
this community the potential health
impacts are more of a concern and
Christine says I'll understand why if I
meet Dulce Ortiz who lives and works
downtown just a stone's throw from the
coal plant oh wow it's right outside
your window huh yes it is what's that
like it's frustrating and inspiring but
dole se tells me she's worried about the
health impact the pollution from the
plants might have on her 14 year-old son
Ivan and her mother Sonya who also lives
in town so where are some of the
personal impacts that the coal plant has
had on you guys
um have our problems with way Long's
constantly you know I never in my life
smoke and it's not just me she started
getting sick too you've developed
similar issues yes is this something
that is more widespread in the community
or is this just your family no it's it's
in the community you know it's bad of
course we can't say that ozma is caused
by the coal plant but the pollution
that's being put out into the air
creates the asthma attacks Dulce
explains that such attacks are common in
Waukegan one study found that one in
three school children had asthma or
asthma-like symptoms a rate far higher
than in the rest of the state
but before meeting Christine Dulce
didn't even realize what the plant
outside her window was you didn't know
no I know you know I told Christine you
know what can I do what do you want me
to do whatever you want me to do I'll do
it
[Music]